that's Jacksonville home to several
military bases and young people who make
a career in the military
at graduation time many high schools
celebrate the college's their students
plan to attend but some districts are
also honoring graduates who decided to
enlist in this service CTM correspondent
and CBS n anchor vladimir duthiers has
the story of a group that's honored high
schoolers heading into uniform for a
decade so Anthony our community salutes
is that organization and it's brought a
brand of celebration to students who are
typically unheralded for choosing the
military over college we were at the
latest ceremony last night in central
New York where students from forty five
school districts were represented it's
about a week before graduation at New
York's Windsor Central High School
[Music]
but this pomp and circumstance is solely
intended to highlight students set on
careers in the military I think it's
great for like the ceremony to happen
because there's not a lot of
representation in the schools but here
this is what it's all about like it's
completely for us we're recognizing you
for what you're about to do
Aaron Evan it's key will graduate second
in her class but instead of heading to
college she enlisted in the army and
plans to become a veterinarian
you'd get hands-on job training in the
army and then afterwards they can pay
for your schooling with the GI Bill and
I can end up being a vet College and all
that schoolwork just doesn't really fit
me I can't really stay at a desk job I
have to be out somewhere doing something
getting my hands dirty Dominic Mastro
Nardi and hi you Olson are headed to the
Marines I chose the Marines I wanted to
challenge only part of her Brotherhood I
just feel like going to serve something
bigger than myself young graduates going
into the military should be honored gene
Clark a director of art community
salutes which has performed more than
thirty of these celebrations to service
in over 20 states this year I hear from
veterans all the time well they never
did this for me when I went in this
service and my response is no they
didn't do it when I went in the service
here
but wouldn't it have been wonderful if
they had Jenna Murdoch US Navy Jenna
Murdock represents the fourth generation
of her family to join the Navy and the
first to be celebrated by her community
for doing so it's kind of a family
legacy almost it's always been an
interest of mine and it seems like it
just kind of made sense to join the Navy
Jenna wants to become a physical
therapist one day and plans to pay for
that education using the GI but I love
that they're doing this it's such a
great idea and I love what he said young
grads going into the military should be
honored we should be paying attention to
them we should be honoring them and
thanking them and I'm glad after ten
years of them doing it we finally
noticed it was the applause well
deserved
exactly exactly thank you very much